les trois opérateurs de téléphonie
mobile sfr bouygues et orange ont
finalement été condamné à une amende de
534 millions d'euros par le conseil de
la concurrence qui leur reprochent de
s'être illégalement entendus pour se
partager le marché français le montant
peut sembler élevé mais le préjudice
pour les consommateurs est lui estimé à
1 milliard 200 millions d'euros
des consommateurs qui ont bien
l'intention d'obtenir réparation et
sylvain philippe rey bon le bas de
combat ce matin à l'ufc que choisir
dès 2002 l'association avait porté
plainte contre les trois opérateurs de
téléphonie mobile condamné mais cette
amende historique d'un demi milliard
d'euros ira directement dans les caisses
de l'état
or pour l'association les premiers lésés
sur les consommateurs
faute de concurrence ils auraient été
surfacturés de plus d'un milliard
d'euros
l'association lance donc aujourd'hui ce
site internet chaque abonné pourra
estimer son éventuel préjudice pour
intenter une action en justice
deux possibilités soit il va tout seul
devant la justice il saisit le juge de
proximité
c'est une action gratuite soit il peut
se joindre à l'action que l'association
ufc que choisir va déposer devant les
tribunaux civils et tous les
consommateurs pour se joindre mais les
abonnés ne sont pas les seuls floués
dans cette affaire les nouveaux
opérateurs tels que tele2 estiment
qu'ils n'ont pu arriver sur le marché
que l'an dernier à cause de cette
entente est pour eux la sanction arrive
trop tard j'aurai beaucoup mieux fallu
encore une fois que
l'état par le régulateur des télécoms ou
par le gouvernement directement agit sur
le marché il ya deux ou trois ans pour
permettre aux nouveaux opérateurs
mobiles de se développer plutôt que
d'agir très brutalement aujourd'hui et
encore une fois les clients n'en
profiteront pas pour l'instant les
marchés ont plutôt bien réagi
aucune des actions a dévissé il est vrai
que les bénéfices de ces opérateurs sont
colossaux mais dans le monde des
affaires on met en garde un peu d'âme
ans de trop lourdes
il est normal il est plutôt sain pour
les consommateurs qui lie à un contrôle
qu'on évite évidemment les ententes
mais de là à vouloir complètement
asphyxié les entreprises ça peut devenir
tout à fait dangereux ils n'ont pas que
ces trois opérateurs créent beaucoup
d'emplois que c'est beaucoup de
croissance également dans notre économie
quant aux trois opérateurs incriminés il
conteste vigoureusement les conclusions
du conseil de la concurrence
on leur reproche de s'être partagé le
marché mais pas d'avoir fait monter les
prix
ils ont donc fait appel depuis